in the United Kingdom
you may ducks chickens geese and nah not
these they all belong to the Queen well
all swans in the United Kingdom can
belong to the Queen but she mainly
exercises this right on the river thames
of course sorry my name is David barber
and I look after the swans wherever the
Queen exercises her royal property
fright it's not a full-time job although
sometimes it feels like a full-time job
every year mr Barber runs a census of
the Swans for Her Majesty a bit like an
annual checkup this is called Swan Appy
and he does it with a whole crew like
this guy this guy and this guy sworn up
in has taken place since the 12th
century where swans in those days were
actually a very very important food of
course today swans are our protected
species and no longer eaten we travel in
six traditional Rowan's gifts from some
Breann Thames all the way up to Abington
and it's about a seventy nine mile
journey what will we say when we say
Swan all up all up each family of swans
we come across we will circle the skiffs
around them we will tie the wings in
their legs we will take them ashore we
will weigh them measure them and check
them for any injuries after we've done
that we will put a ring on them and we
will release them back into the river so
if these are the Queen swans weighs Her
Majesty for all of this she did come one
up in a few years ago and hopefully she
enjoyed it she seemed to enjoy it but I
card Arts
the Queen anyway I love swans a royal
bird people here in the United Kingdom
they love them and you know I want to
make sure that they survive for the
future all right gents let's toast